[Musique]
en cette fin de mois de décembre 1870 le
désespoir semble gagner belfort déjà
près de 60 jours de siège et les
prussiens sont de plus en plus nombreux
la tristesse envahi nos espérances je
maudis tous les promoteurs de guerre
écrit le soldat françois-joseph tio et
pourtant
une délégation suisse propose bien
d'évacuer une partie de la population
mais denfert rochereau méfiant refusent
les conditions des prussiens
c'est à véritable scandale pour la
population et même pour le maire de
belfort et de l'arménie
un tel point que edward mais ni va
convoquer un conseil municipal
extraordinaire
c'est le seul qui aura lieu durant le
siège de belfort pour voter une motion
condamnant aux yeux de l'histoire
cette position du collège denfert
rochereau et puis en janvier s'est de
nouveau l'espoir une armée est en route
elle vient libérer belfort le ministre
léon gambetta à himidi audacieux qui va
même surprendre l'armée prussienne le
grand état major prussiens du général
faune polk c'est à dire de détacher une
partie des troupes sur la loire et de
les amener en franche comté pour libérer
belfort et atteindre les communications
plus hier en alsace c'est le général
bourbaki qui commandent ces tarnais
à la mi janvier 1871 elle se déploie du
côté d'héricourt belfort n'est plus qu'à
quelques kilomètres mais les prussiens
sont là avec leur canon on voit arriver
cent trente mille hommes qui sont
arrivés depuis bourges depuis lyon
depuis dijon avec des marches forcées
transportés dans des trains dans des
conditions assez abominable avec très
peu de nourriture un mauvais équipement
et puis en face très organisée avec de
l'artillerie et au moment où ils sortent
des bois ça va être une boucherie au
canon
du côté allemand on peut dire que c'est
un véritable coup de poker sire que
numériquement l'armée allemande est plus
faible mais elle a un avantage sur
général bourbaki c qu'elle s'est
retranché derrière des fortifications
alors naturelles comme la rivière li
zhen les allemands vont s'employer à
casser régulièrement la glace pour
éviter que on puisse traverser la
lizaine sans passer par les ponts
traverser la rivière de la lizaine
c'était la porte ouverte en direction de
belfort
un tel point qu'à un moment donné les
prussiens ou même envisagé d'évacuer les
batteries de canons de sièges qui tirait
sur la ville tellement la situation
était tendue pour l'armée de bourbaki
est épuisée et le général hésite à
avancer
il a tort les prussiens prennent
davantage c'est la déroute aujourd'hui
près de la lizaine des monuments
témoigne de ce que fut la dernière
grande bataille de cette guerre
dans les jours qui suivent donc cette
armée de l'est qui quittent le champ de
bataille la lizaine pour aller en
direction de la suisse puisque c'est son
seul salut pour ne pas être fait
prisonnier par les troupes allemandes
qui sont à ses trousses bien durant
cette période le général bourbaki il a
essayé d'attenter à sa vie en se tirant
une balle dans la tête qui va
heureusement l'épargné puisqu'il meurt
en 1897 donc puis de 25 ans après les
faits belfort ne sera donc pas libérés
mais peu importe dans sa case mate
denfert rochereau tient bon sa stratégie
fonctionne on n'est pas dans une guerre
dans les guerres du 20e siècle
c'est à dire si on avait une certaine
méfiance l'un pour l'autre
cela ne va pas empêcher des fois ce que
le colonel denfert rochereau à applique
des paies ta site
c'est à dire des moments où les
sentinelles française les sentinelles
prussienne vont échanger de l'alcool
quelques denrées en février 1871 les
soldats de l'empiré allemand vont
pourtant faire sauter l'un des verrous
essentiel de la défense de la ville le
fort des basses perche
[Musique]